c'est beau ce qu'il a dit je dis juste
une phrase puisque je vois que vous
voulez tous réagir il a dit c'est très
égoïste d'aimer une jeune fille elle est
jeune et puis je vais lui faire du mal
quand tu vas déco je vais disparaître je
me suis dit toutes ces choses là elle a
été plus forte que moi je vais voir dans
ses yeux qu'elle était heureuse avec moi
alors j'ai cédé c'est beau ce qu'il dit
quand même Benoît ben non mais tomber
amoureux c'est tombé tout court tu
choisis pas comme ça tombe dessus ouais
je sais je l'ai lu dans un livre
ils ont 35 ans d'écart comme il a 150
l'âge enfin l'amour n'a pas d'âge si je
peux me permettre on choisit pas c'est
moi je suis tombé amoureux de certaines
personnes qui avaient la personne qui
était le plus d'écart d'âge avec toi de
c'était c'était quoi la phrase c'est pas
français mais j'ai compris
en famille et en famille non mais on
pense souvent que c'est le jeune qui
quitte mais c'est vous c'est souvent
c'est souvent la personne plus âgée qui
n'a plus confiance et qui a peur de se
faire quitter par le jeune et en général
c'est toujours le jeune qui est
malheureux ça c'est vrai bon évidemment
vous me voyez venir pardon mais
pardon ce qui est un peu plus âgé moi je
pense que ça fait peur toi non parce que
la vie est imprévisible on sait jamais
ce qui peut se passer on vit le moment
présent quand on aime c'est sincère on a
envie de passer du temps avec la
personne peu importe le temps que ça va
durer mieux vaut vivre plusieurs années
de bonheur avec quelqu'un où on est
heureux plutôt que encore plus d'années
on n'est pas heureux moi j'ai 34 ans
est-ce que tu t'étais dit peut-être un
jour que tu avais 25 26 ans que
peut-être un jour tu sortiras avec
quelqu'un de 60 non je m'étais jamais
posé la question c'était pas posé la
question je m'étais dit que je voulais
être heureux donc vu que je le suis
aujourd'hui je suis content et après ça
durera le temps que ça durera et oui
après la vie c'est sûr qu'il y a plus de
chance qu'il partent avant moi oui c'est
évident non ça veut rien mais on ne sait
pas ce moment-là tu seras très riche et
tu te mettras avec moi parce que moi
c'est comme ça
[Applaudissements]
plusieurs années nous sépare aussi mais
oui oui oui il va repartir pour quatre
émissions parce que tu as amusant quand
même c'est que tu tiens avec une
personne plus âgée toi tu aimes bien les
personnes plus âgées Ayem tu aimes bien
les personnes plus âgées toi tu peux pas
mathématiquement ça sera pas possible
que je trouve ce que je trouve très chic
et très classe de la part de Monsieur
Serge Lama c'est d'avoir justement ce
recul et de se dire bah ma femme va
sûrement refaire sa vie après moi et je
suis en accord avec ça je trouve ça très
chic de sa part moi qui a vécu justement
avec un homme plus âgé vous avez 30 ans
d'écart 25 ans d'écart c'est quand même
déjà énorme il était hors de question
pour lui que je refasse ma vie après
son départ
vous avez pas les mêmes aussi les mêmes
les mêmes envies les occupations moi je
suis plus mature lui il était très jeune
très festif et moi j'avais besoin de
maturité de choses plus stable plus
calme donc oui mais regardez du Godard
et toi tu regardes Bob l'éponge il y a
pas un moment où non
pas du Godard enfin un peu de bon sens
on fait une expo au Grand Palais
[Musique]
un certain nombre de points communs
qu'on partage et puis les choses que
j'ai envie de faire ou qu'il a envie de
faire par exemple et que ça on n'a pas
ce point commun et ben faire chacun de
notre côté par exemple
c'était sans lui voilà exactement voilà
oui Natacha j'avais juste envie de dire
je suis d'accord avec avec Ayem c'est
que il y a vraiment la plupart des
hommes on va dire plus mûrs plus âgées
etc
on vit ça de façon assez égoïste et sans
sans voir l'avenir ce qu'il y avait de
terriblement bouleversant chez Serge
Lama parce que j'ai regardé son
oui mais c'est surtout c'est quelqu'un
qui a conscience de de que la vie
avance vers sa fin inéluctable et en ce
qui le concerne il l'a cette mesure là
il a cette humilité là et je pense que
son amour c'est un amour avec un grand A
c'est à dire ça voilà
qui habite dans un certain
arrondissement de Paris je dirais pas
lequel qui habite les volets fermés
toute la journée il habite dans le noir
du matin au soir non pas bien avant bien
avant il ne supportait pas la lumière
alors Jean-Mi et Isaac pardon
avec une fille qui était beaucoup plus
jeune que à peu près 25 ans de moins
aussi et je pensais que tout allait bien
et je me suis rendu compte un jour
peut-être elle se posait des questions
pour l'avenir parce que j'ai à manger vu
dans son historique Google qui avait
tapé à quel âge comment ces problèmes
d'érections
il commence à se projeter un peu ouais
savoir combien de temps je vais tenir un
peu projette pas peut-être qu'elle était
dans le présent quand même tu vois pas
faux pas faux mais ça là-dessus on est
très bien équipé hein comment non je dis
sur les problèmes d'érection on est on a
et oui non pour les hommes pour les
hommes on a des complètement
à 14h on va tirer un coup non mais c'est
vrai faut pas prévoir mais si tu as un
bon ami comme ça on dit tout en temps
tout texto absurde voilà allez on passe
à Isabelle est-ce que vous allez dire
quoi
jusqu'à la maladie de mon mari te dire
jusqu'à 68 ans il ne sait absolument pas
ce que c'est que les problèmes
d'érection
[Applaudissements]
qu'on a fait exprès de voisinage
beaucoup plus âgés c'est terrible c'est
le moment où on se rend compte que les
hommes beaucoup plus âgés bah ils
regardent les tranches d'âge beaucoup
plus jeune et que vous commencez à
intéresser des jeunes qui ne vous
intéressent toujours pas oui ça c'est
vrai c'est c'est très particulier
était vraiment passionnante et très
touchant parce qu'il a rappelé qu'il
avait des problèmes de santé depuis
l'âge de 22 ans de voiture et la légende
qui fonctionnent pratiquement plus et
justement au lieu de ça s'acharner comme
beaucoup d'artistes il préfère se mettre
un petit peu en retraite c'est à dire
arrêter la scène notamment pour être
plus proche de sa compagne et le temps
qu'il lui reste était très mignon